brent's with us in boise idaho hey brent
what's up
hey y'all thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help questions for ken
um so i just started um a new job
a month or two ago um and i accepted uh
my salary
and i was happy enough with it um and
then i found out that my coworkers
are making about 50 more than i do like
45
what do you make um and i was wondering
i'm making 22 an hour
doing what uh medical lab scientists
and they're making 33 an hour
uh yeah 32. are they measurably more
experienced than you
uh no
how did you come about this we're all
dealing how did you get this information
i'm from them there's
two of us that work on this particular
two others and then me
that we're working on this one we're
dealing with kobe
well i gotta lean i i gotta tell you i i
gotta lean a little bit on dave i got
some thoughts but dave is tired
a lot no no but you've got a unique
perspective on how many people you've
hired and fired in culture development
but i
so so this is really challenging okay
because this is all psychology and
you're human
and so you've gotta you're gonna have to
rise above this is the straightforward
answer
uh because if you don't this is going to
eat you alive
and i don't think you'll last very long
uh this is the the natural comparison
uh in comparison is a cancer the only
person i try to compare myself to is the
me of yesterday
and and that's hard but that's what you
got to do
um because if if you're saying things
are equal
and it's an equal playing field they
don't have any more experience than you
they don't have any additional
uh excuse me certifications or all that
stuff
uh this is a really nasty situation to
find out about i got to tell you i'm
slight bit
cynical maybe suspect that you got the
information from them i'm not saying
they lied to you but
the whole thing just stinks and if you
want to be there here's the last piece
if you want to be there in the sense
that it's the latter you need to be on
for your career and where you eventually
want to get to and you got to be on this
rung to get to the next rung
then you're going to have to really suck
it up and be the better man here and
and stay out of this kind of stuff and
and earn the next
rung if you can't handle that then
you're eventually probably
going to self-select and have to get out
of there and i'm sorry that it's
happened to you because it's a real
devastating psychological blow
it's a really good question you brought
to the forefront here and the
interesting thing about it is your tone
when you're asking the question is not
whiny you're just like it's
it's like a curiosity to you which is a
positive thing so there's not a
you're not angry or bitter or something
like that you're just like this doesn't
make sense
it's like a scientist right i mean it's
there's a riddle here
and so um i'm gonna join you in the
riddle why would you
if you were to guess why the discrepancy
in pay what would you guess
um because they are i mean
it's a business or hospital they're just
trying to get as little
um or pay as little i came from a
so you don't think it's an oversight um
you know they're you don't think they
saw something different in your
qualifications than the other guy
you don't think there's a logical
explanation other than just sheer they
didn't want to pay as much and they
thought they could get away with it and
they did
and they did i didn't come in i thought
the job was a technician job not a
technologist job
and so when they gave me my pay i was
like well this is really exciting yes
i'll take this because it's like four
bucks more than i thought it was gonna
be
um and then i found out what the job
really entailed i
am a biochemist not a medical life
scientist
actually um yeah i've been learning to
play golf and i figured out the secret
to happiness is
low expectations um yeah
so yeah you had low expectations and
then you got a four dollars more and you
thought this is wonderful and then you
found out you're ten dollars under
and it's all about expectations what ken
said it's a psychological problem
so what is the environment like uh
what's the environment like between you
and your supervisor or you're hiring the
person that did the hiring with you
is this a an open conversational good
people or is it very chain of command
real shut your mouth get your work done
i mean what is it authoritative or
that is a great question um the only
time i've met my supervisor
is the day i was interviewed she went on
leave right after that
and then has since come back from leave
and has never stepped in
and i'm a night shift and so i haven't
she's gone before i come in yeah
well i um what i have figured out is
that there's going to be a difficult
conversation
it is going to be in your head and your
head's going to explode
or eventually or you're going to have a
difficult conversation
and the the trick is how to sit down
with her
and have a difficult conversation and
what one of the things we teach leaders
to do
and uh you're leading up in this
situation
is to just if if if there's an elephant
in the room go
hey there's an elephant over there don't
act like he's not there and so let's
just call out
a couple things that we know here okay
number one
when i interviewed for this job i first
thought it was
this and then i found out it was that
and i was four dollars more than i
thought and so i was really happy
and i'm grateful and by the way i am
grateful for the job
and i have not gotten to talk to you a
lot because you've been out on leave and
of course i'm night shift
but i'm swinging by this afternoon to
have a five minute meeting with you
just uh and i want you to hear nothing
but gratitude from me
but i got to talking to the other guys
in the lab and i found out that i'm the
only guy with the exact same
qualifications that makes
22 and they all make 32. and what i want
to ask you
is what can i do to make myself worth
32 to you guys because i'd like to
measure up
and apparently i've not done that yet
and that pretty well exposes the crap
without you going you people ripped me
off you know
that's the other way to approach it in
which case you just get fired brent
really quick let me jump and ask this
question
are you able to do the market research
and be able to show
that there's a range of income and that
the work you're actually doing
uh does pay higher can is that is that
something you can find the evidence for
and show that in the marketplace
um there is they are actually
above average what the other two are
making yeah
well what i would do i would just say
all of this
yeah i just say number one i'm happy at
22 i'm not coming in here to gripe about
them making more
number two i know that the pay around
here is above average in general
but what i'm trying to do is figure out
how i can be more valuable to this place
so that i can be worth it
and you put me in for a 32 instead of a
22. but i want to earn it and
i want you to tell me how i can be the
best person i need to be to do that and
i don't want you to hear anything from
me but gratitude listen if
if your boss gets twisted up about that
your boss is an idiot yeah
there's your sign that's not a long-term
stay
yeah the only thing they go shut up and
get in your corner you accepted the job
right then uh then start looking for
another position but but i don't think
they will
i think you're bringing it up and what
you're doing is you're exposing the fact
that
all of these facts are here oh by the
way you can also say
i accepted the job at 22. so i did this
deal
and i'm so i can't come in and gripe
about the deal i'm not here to gripe
about the deal i took the job
and uh and so you know the fact that
somebody else makes more does not make
me unhappy
but what i do want to do is i want to
figure out a track that i can get on to
be of value to this place
to where i can join them in that kind of
an income
because that would make me feel really
fulfilled and i would know that i did a
good job for you guys
and that kind of just keep talking about
that way but you know hey i took the job
i
i did the deal so i got no gripes
because
i if you'd have been 32 if i'd been 42
if it had been
you know whatever number you'd have
taken the job and so you took the job
you know and just admit that admit that
you're you're grateful
and that we don't have a relationship
because i'm not seeing you
and just put all these things that are
facts out on the table so that
that there's nothing swirling around as
a side
uh communication that's not happening
and be real careful with your body
language your tone and your pacing
and be real calm like you've been with
us and not whiny
if you're octave down no high octaves
this is the ramsay show